[Applause]
signals breaking up command i'll do one
last scan see you soon over
okay
[Music]
[Music]
command i
may be onto something
[Music]
i have it command repeat i have it
mission accomplished
hang tight doc i've got this
[Music]
[Applause]
glad you could make it we gotta move
now
there's a storm coming
and hell's coming with it
have it tim congratulations stormgate is
real we have a name and some details uh
so first of all congratulations on this
announcement we're so excited about the
return of rts brand new uh franchise
what is a stormgate though all right so
stormgates are portals that open during
a massive solar storm that unleashed the
infernal host on future earth
okay uh and we saw some hints of some i
mean you know you guys coming from
blizzard and starcraft everyone wants to
know about races uh you know tell us
about the sides in this rts game yeah
we're unveiling our first two factions
today but there will be more uh so the
human resistance and we saw an
archaeologist from the human resistance
in that
intro cinematic uh and then also the
infernal hosts who are these demon-like
monsters who come from another world
i think one thing everyone wants to know
about especially your background
pedigree of the team of you know where
do you want to push the rts genre it's
something we've all loved for decades
but you know opportunity for a lot of
innovation
i know you're going to show us i think
some some hints of where you're going to
go image-wise with the actual gameplay
made in unreal engine but any sense of
what you want to do for the game play in
this game
absolutely i but the first thing i want
to say is we are very consciously trying
to stay true to what players already
love about rts
where we're really trying to push the
genre and be innovative first off
approachability
for one thing we're free to play
but no pay to win no nfts nothing like
that
just to
lower that barrier to entry to get
players in but we're also really trying
to be a lot more social so you'll be
able to play the campaign cooperatively
we've got three player open-ended co-op
and we've even got three versus three
for competitive multiplayer but of
course we've also still got 1v1
competitive and as a little surprise i
think we've got some first kind of work
in progress images from the game right
yeah these are still very much still
being worked on but some shots of uh
actual assets that we're building in
unreal engine 5. wow well i i love it
2023 you said for the betas people can
sign up now get ready and i'm just so
thrilled that there is a a brand new rts
franchise coming from you guys and your
background and what you did you know
blizzard and starcraft we're so excited
about this team frost giant uh thank you
so much for giving us your announcement
today on summer game fest thank you so
much for having us here really grateful
awesome all right frost giant stormgate
keep an eye out for it now it's time for
a